- Expression my mother often uses,
that you do the right
things for the right reasons
and you live with the consequences.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] You got your perspective.
(car revving)
(upbeat music continues)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(lively cheerful music)
Everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Really exciting day for me
because I admire the gentlemen
that I will be interviewing quite a bit
and have for a very long time.
And we spent two seconds
getting to know each other
talking of course football
and we'll get into that in a minute.
But as many of you know,
who follow my content,
I haven't done a whole
lot of interviews lately.
And to be Frank, I think that
interacting with all of you
and answering your questions
has been really fruitful.
And I wanna save the
interviews on the podcast
for special occasions, one that excites me
or one that I think
can disproportionately
bring value to the audience
and this showman hits on both fronts.
So without further ado,
I'd like to introduce,
Arthur Blank to the show.
I will let this prestigious
gentlemen introduce himself
'cause I'm curious to hear
how he positions himself these days.
And he's got a new book out
and I know how much my
audience has enjoyed
getting to know authors around books
and have been big supporters.
So I hope the Vayner nation
can climb some Amazon
and Barnes and Noble's ratings
and things of that nature.
So, excited for the
new book, good company.
So, Arthur, how are you?
- I'm fine.
It's an honor to chat
with you for a little bit.
The other thing which we share
and we probably share a
lot of things in common,
but we both came from Queens.
- That's right.
- And so I have that diversity
and that life experience in my background.
But today, I co-founded
The Home Depot in 1979,
their first stores and left in 2001.
And we were the second
largest retail in the world
at that time.
And today the company has a book value
or capital value I should
say, of close to 300 million,
$300 billion.
And I transitioned into
a variety of other things
to the Atlanta Falcons
which you mentioned,
Atlanta United, our
Major League Soccer team.
We operate the PGA Tour Superstores
which is the largest golf
retail in America today.
We operate several
guest ranches in Montana
rated number one in the
western part of the country.
And we have a very active
and philanthropic family foundation.
So we're involved in a lot of things.
And I think the beauty of the book
and the essence of the
book is that all the values
that we cultivated and developed
at Home Depot for 23 years
are now being shepherd along
beautifully by Craig Menear
and their whole team.
Are the same values we put in place
in all of these different
industries, in different settings
different geographies.
With fans, customers, and
guests, all three of them
through our associates and
connected to the communities
that we live in.
And really the emphasis of the stories
and the thoughts
throughout the book is that
you can't have both profitability
and emphasis on the people
side of the equation.
In fact, if you're gonna have,
really gonna achieve both at high levels
you need to achieve both.
You need to put emphasis on both of them
and one feeds the other very strongly.
So, it's a great book,
not because I wrote it.
It's not really about me,
but it's about the values
which we think are transportable
to virtually every business
for profit or non-profit
as the case may be.
- Arthur, I think this is where we share
a lot of perspective.
To me I call my VaynerX, my universe.
I call it the honey empire.
I have enormous ambitions,
I'd like to match the
accomplishments you have.
Especially 'cause I wanna
buy the New York Jets.
(Arthur laughs)
And, but I also think that you can do that
with honey over vinegar.
I'm uncomfortable actually,
In deep negativity and bad human traits.
And I enjoy the part
of my career right now
because I have a lot of kids watching me
on these social networks and (indistinct).
I started a wine brand,
it's called Empathy.
Like these things to me and
you were pioneering it before.
I think people are confused
that you don't have to kill people
or be mean to be a
successful business person.
I think that's what I heard
in your opening statement.
- Yeah, well, I think not only,
you don't have to be that way.
I think it's counter being successful.
And I'm measuring success
really in two ways.
One is the financial
results, which obviously
is what most people
conventionally would think of.
But also in terms of
having purpose in life
and you don't have to be
someone like Deepak Chopra
who's a good friend and
endorsed the book and read it.
But you have to understand that
young people today particularly
I think are striving
for more purpose than I think
they've ever done so in the past.
An example and you're
probably familiar with this
is Dr. Laurie Santos,
who also read the book
and endorses it.
Who has a professor of
psychology at the University.
She started this course,
as you probably know,
on happiness, her happiness lab,
because 30-40 kids said to her,
there has to be more
in life than just this
there has to be more in life
than just making money, et
cetera, and being successful.
She now, as many of your
listeners may be aware.
She now, she teaches that class
to a quarter of the student body
of Yale University at a time, one quarter.
It's largest enrollment
class they've ever had
in the history of Yale
- My God!
- 205 years old, and it's now
available to everybody online.
So you pass that onto your listeners too.
It's available online and
it's done beautifully.
So--
- Arthur let me ask a question.
I'm sorry to interrupt
- Yeah
- But I wanna get so much out of you
in this short time together.
What kind of kid were you?
(Arthur laughs)
Like I'm very, very curious.
- Well I was very competitive.
I was very competitive.
And my focus really growing up was sports.
I played football, ran
track, played baseball,
for my high school.
And I was really a good
athlete I would say.
Not good enough to go to the next level.
And I pretty much banged
myself up in my junior year
playing football.
We had a great football team
at Stuyvesant High School in New York.
My junior year we won all of our games.
Average score was like 40-46,
I think something like that.
(Gary laughs)
So we had a really good team.
We had a bunch of young men that went on
and got full scholarships and played well
and collegiately, but I've
always been competitive--
- Were your...
So I don't know if you know this
'cause I know you knew,
it sounds like you knew the Queen's part.
But I was actually born in Belarus
in the former Soviet Union.
- No, I didn't know that.
- Yeah, and I came over in 78
when they let a small amount of Jews out,
when Israel and America,
you might remember this Jury
- I do.
- Was able to get...
So that is my origin story
and I've always felt, and I
tell a lot of my contemporaries
in their late 30s, early 40s
that are business men
and women (indistinct)
When we get into these dinners,
I'm like you have to understand,
I'm far more like your grandfather
than I am like you, because
I lived in a studio apartment
with seven family members.
Like I remember that.
This is not my...
I think that you grew up
in a Queens, in your years.
Hey, was it your parents or grandparents
that came over from the old country?
- It was my grandparents.
- Right, so to me, I'm curious.
How much do you think the environment
that you grew up in lent
itself to the acceleration
of your competitiveness?
Because it's obviously a do or die game,
but it's also clearly an environment game.
And looking at your timing
of when you were growing up in Queens,
I'm always romantic about
that era as a historian,
'cause I think a lot of
good chips on shoulders
and ruggedness that led to
great success to your point
both happy and algorithmic
and kind of financial.
There's a lot of men and
women that came from that era.
And there's something in the water,
something you hear a lot.
I feel like there's something in the water
for those Italian, Jews,
Irishmen, immigrants, kids,
and grandkids of immigrants
in that New York at your era.
- Well, that's a really good point.
And I think, yes there was
something in the water.
And I think the water at
that point was going through
the experience of your
parents coming through
Ellis Island, settling in lower Manhattan,
often without anything
to speak of financially.
We were working any number of jobs
to just maintain a sense
of keeping family together
and supporting each other.
And so, I think the notion of overcoming
that form of adversity, if you will,
or those challenges,
I wouldn't say adversity, but challenges.
I think we've really done
beautifully by our families.
And so I think in my family,
given the fact I lost my dad
when I was only 15 years old
he was 44.
And so I think that that puts
some emphasis on my mind--
- By the way, I have another
connection point for us.
And I realized my father, at the same ages
on both his father and himself,
lost his dad at 15, when my grandfather
was 44, yeah.
- Oh wow!
That's amazing, wow!
Well, that's a real connection here.
So, my mother went into his
business without any background
that he had started in his early forties
and she ran it beautifully
and eventually sold it.
And so I think the notion of
pushing through challenges,
looking for challenges,
looking for opportunities
to enhance, to make the world
a better place, if you will.
My mother was a woman of principle.
I think that became very important to me
at an early age and the
expression my mother often uses
that you do the right
things for the right reasons
and you live with the consequences.
I think that stayed with me for many years
and drives a lot of the
the cultural aspects
of what we talk about in the book.
- I'm gonna stop you there because I think
when people ask me why I
have this honey empire thing?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I literally say my mom,
my mom...
First of all, I share her DNA.
So being nice and kind.
And by the way, I'm
uncomfortably competitive
which actually confuses people.
Actually, it's a good question, Arthur,
since you're many years
and success ahead of me
on this journey, but I'm very curious.
And maybe it's the
climate we live in today,
'cause obviously, it's
always a timing thing.
But, do you feel that people actually
confuse individuals that are competitive
and don't realize that
it's actually very easy
to coexist with kindness
and competitiveness,
but that sometimes competitiveness
especially in the heat
of the moment manifests
to something that seems a
little bit more aggressive
and not naturally kind,
And that confuses some outside observers?
- Yeah, I think it can.
But, people that I have great respect for
even making, being as
firm as they want to be
in making the points they need to make
and strong as need to make it,
have always found a way to do it
with a degree of kindness.
And I go back to Dr. King
two of his closest disciples
are close friends of mind.
One just passed away, John Lewis,
who was a very close friend
and Andy Yango still lives in Atlanta.
Two of the closest to Dr. King.
And another gentleman brought to fore
in the book, Jimmy Carter.
One of the kindest thoughtful,
most caring people I've met
in my life and yet extremely competitive.
I mean, there's a story
I talk about in the book
where we were climbing rocks
together within a bound course
and his wife got up on
top sooner than he did.
So I said, Mr President, this
was after he left office,
have you had enough?
I remember he looked at me,
sweaty, sweaty, sweaty eyes, everything.
He said, no.
He said, we're not leaving
until I make this climb.
And he did, but, so I
think you can have both.
- It's funny, I agree.
But the way I think about it and obviously
a lot of people don't realize
how much success you have
in soccer, proper football
with your club there too.
I do think the physical manifestation
versus the boardroom communication style
does have a little bit of a tweak, right?
I see a lot of people to your point
that I see do a great job in the boardroom
managing their people, managing
up, down, left and right.
But then you get them
in to pickup basketball
and they're throwing
an elbow in your chest
'cause that's where you get to see their
physical manifestation.
- Well, yeah.
(crosstalk)
I think that I can relate to that.
And I would say (indistinct)
(Gary laughs)
I was always very competitive
and I still am today.
I don't like to lose anything, I remember,
A brief story, I remember my wife and I,
first year we got married,
we played Scrabble.
We played 24, 24.
The first one who won 25 games
is gonna be the champion of Scrabble.
And I told this to a team,
a football team in 2001, they
asked me, are you competitive?
So we played the last game of Scrabble
with no time limits on it.
I lost that.
We were married 27 years.
We never played another game of Scrabble.
- I love you already.
- So, I don't like to lose
(Gary laughs)
but, anyway, but it's--
- Remind me, is the book out
or about to be out.
- It's out.
- It's out--
- It's out, it was
published September 15th
and it's out available on
all the booking outlets
you can imagine.
- What has been the most surprising?
For me, I've written five
business books and one wine book
I grew up in the wine
business of all things.
My dad has a liquor store in
New Jersey that I transformed
to an early dot-com wine business.
The one thing I liked with
all six of those processes
was the feedback.
'Cause you're in your
book for a period of time.
The feedback that you didn't see coming.
I think this may be a fun question
that might have some insights.
Any feedback from a random email
or somebody close to you of
an observation from the book
that you had not thought
of but you appreciated
or that kind of has caught
your attention so far here
in the couple of weeks that it's been out.
- Well, I think it's a great question.
I don't know, but I'll
be seeking the answer.
- Okay.
- Because I have told
people who've read it
or halfway through it or whatever,
I'm really interested in
their critique of the book.
I mean as you've experienced,
when you write one of these books
and you go through them,
after a while you fall in love
with what you're writing
and you finally sign off on it.
It's the best product
that you can produce at
that time, et cetera.
And it tells your story,
whatever story it may be.
But how other people see it,
and there are a handful of people
that I have deep respect for
that I'm interested in
getting their feedback.
And I'm sure they'll
give it to me too, so.
- Do you look at this as a legacy piece?
Because you feel like that
one of your natural talents.
And, by the way, I'm such a buyer
of an important thing you said.
I have literally told every CFO,
overly financially driven friend
of mine, because I tend to,
even though I have these big ambitions,
obsessed with the process,
more than actually the dollars
that come along with it.
I've told them all the time,
I believe that kindness actually
is a practical financial impact there.
And, my heart was smiling
and my brain was smiling,
when you said the same.
Do you view this as a
legacy piece for you?
Because you do think that it is a,
it's a nuance that comes natural to you,
that you've executed on
and your partners at Depot.
Do you feel like this is something
that you think is
misunderstood (indistinct)
- Yeah I do Gary, but
it's interesting because
it was just last year 2019,
probably a lot of the people
that you're referring to
or maybe some of the
people you're referring to
were part of the business round table.
So in 2019, after 50 years
of being in business,
that round table, they
changed their charter
to saying, our emphasis
is not just gonna be
return on profitability.
It's gonna be people, planet and profits.
All balanced out, keeping
in mind our associates
and our suppliers and
our communities as well.
So even that group of 192 CEOs,
even they have changed their emphasis.
And it goes back into Milton Friedman.
The great economist
wrote a book 50 years ago
and said the purpose of a
corporation is to make money
for shareholders, period.
That's the end of the discussion.
Today I think the view is different.
It's changing, I think.
And that's really the
emphasis of the book,
is that I think you can have both.
And I think you need both,
one enhances the other.
It's not that you have to have one
or the other or one takes
away from the other.
The beauty of a weighted
barbell on both ends
that is balanced is that,
it's equally weighted.
And I think the story in this book is that
those good values, that
based on human relationships,
between who you're serving,
who's doing the serving
and the community you're
living in and profitability
are all equally important.
At the end of the day, you want people
that work for you, Gary,
or people that work for me
to feel like this is not
just about making money.
It's about I'm committing
myself to an organization,
that's making a difference in the world.
That's making a difference
in other people's lives.
And you're following comments
because those people are listening to you.
'cause they believe what
you're sharing with them
is making a difference in their lives
and you are happy to share with them--
- To your point, I'm reverse engineering,
bringing value for them, not myself,
which I understand the karma of that.
It has a practical impact
on giving the opportunity for myself.
It's not super complicated.
It's good builds on good.
- Exactly right.
And that's, when you develop
that kind of relationship
with who you're serving.
So, like in our stadium, as an example,
we haven't had a couple of good years,
our soccer team has been super relative
since we started the franchise
three and a half years ago.
The last couple of years our football team
has been very average compared
to the Jets, maybe better,
but not a whole lot better,
(Gary laughs)
but not a whole lot better.
- By the way.
- It's not been great.
- By the way, I'm sorry to interrupt you.
I know we were trying to do
this a couple of weeks ago.
Schedules, when I, I don't
wanna even bring this up
because I know how spicy I get after.
I was watching your
football game this Sunday.
And I said, Oh boy, this is,
this dude is going to be so ...
Because that one hurt.
- Oh, it really hurt.
I mean, it's just, when
you have that kind of lead,
you have to go back.
Your listeners probably
don't really wanna know this.
The Jets may hold a similar record,
but you have to go back to 1933
when a team scored 39
points, had zero turnovers
and lost the game.
So, and on top of that, we had
turnover ratio of plus three.
So, I mean, anyway,
we've already moved on.
we gotta play the bears next Sunday.
- That's right.
- Coaches, players, we've all moved on--
(crosstalk)
- I wanna jump in here on this.
Very curious.
Has there been a challenge
transitioning the sports
coming from the business
world, where it feels to me,
and this is almost the
most selfish question
in podcast history, because I'm
starting to mentally prepare
for hopefully my great dream coming true.
I'm already thinking through things like
in my business life, I feel
like I have more control
than I do with injuries and football.
You gotta give a GM or a
coach, some breathing room
even when intuitively you're concerned.
Just out of sheer curiosity,
how does one find the balance
of being able to control things?
For example, somebody that has
a great interview with you.
I don't know how many coaches you've had
in your ownership, but
you've been through this.
I've been through this.
And even in my young
career, it feels right,
right up to the second.
And then literally a
week later you like, Oh!
I'm trying to see that with
players, kids you've drafted.
I've seen it, a million times over.
My brother left my company
and started an NFL
representation business.
As a matter of fact, we have (indistinct)
which is my company represents your player
that forced three fumbles
and one being this last week
(crosstalk)
- You're a very smart guy
and a terrific person.
And obviously a great player.
Probably, the coach once
said it probably be the best.
Maybe the best 17 minutes
a linebacker has ever had--
- By the way, even more fun.
We also, we also represent
Keith D Beef, the fullback.
And so--
- A very nice young man
- Very nice, so, I watch a lot
of your team because of that.
Tell me what it took to calibrate
the inability to act
when you wanted to act.
Which I think is slightly different
than running a company where
then you have sometimes wait as well
but not to the same
level of degrees I think
when there's a sports franchise
because of so many other variables in it.
- Well, it's really interesting.
I think that one good
piece of advice I got
from Robert Kraft, who owns the Patriots,
he's a good friend of mine.
And when I bought the team in 2001,
we had breakfast together.
I was in New York with
commissioner (indistinct)
going through my owns orientation.
And he said, why don't
you hang around one day
have breakfast tomorrow with Robert.
And I said, I'd be happy to do that.
So I did.
And one of the things Robert said to me
was that you're gonna
hear from a lot of people
that the NFL is a different business.
You're gonna hear that it's...
Run the NFL, run your franchise,
just like you're run the Home Depot
and you're gonna be successful.
Now the one thing that's different,
two things are different.
One of which you pointed out,
when somebody has an injury,
God forbid if Matt Ryan gets hurt
(crosstalk)
The team is in a different place.
Whereas in business,
Matt Ryan breaks a leg,
he gets a cast on, he
comes to work the next day.
So you're not losing him.
- That's right.
- The other thing which
is different is that
the amount of media
coverage, which is involved
with the NFL and therefore
all 32 teams is incredible.
So when Robert said
that to me, I said well,
Home Depot, we took the company public
we're the second largest
retail in the world today.
and, et cetera.
(Crosstalk)
He looked at me and he winked,
like you do, sometimes you do.
I don't know If you
have any children, Gary.
- Yeah, I do.
- If you have a young child
sometimes they won't understand something.
So you'll say at some point in your life,
you'll understand this.
But remember I said it.
So he's turned out to be right.
The media coverage on
the NFL was incredible.
And so, other than those
two things it's really,
and that's the beauty of the book.
It talks about football,
soccer, guest ranching,
philanthropy, golf
retailing, same values apply.
You have the same kind
of successes available
and in a balanced way.
- (indistinct) my own
enjoyment, where do you sit?
Obviously so much of my career
is gonna be built it looks
like on the foundation of
modern communication, right?
I was an early investor
into Facebook and Twitter.
And my communications company spends
a lot of time on that in the
most ironic of ironic things.
I was on a call this morning,
for the first time by
the way, in the 11 years
that I've run my company with Home Depot,
because we've just won
a significant amount
of business with Scotts Miracle-Gro.
And we were having a business meeting.
So it's been a Home Depot kind of day.
- Oh, great.
- I was just curious.
And we were having very
progressive conversations
around Hulu and Amazon Prime Commercials
versus Network Television Commercials.
We've already seen the NFL
start to dabble with Amazon, right?
There's a lot going on there.
Just out of general
curiosity, you the human.
What is your relationship
with the social networks
and digital?
Obviously it comes super
natural for the 16 year olds.
But it's very interesting to see
like, do you have a LinkedIn account?
Do you have a Facebook account?
Did any of your kids or
grandkids get you on Tik Tok?
Like where are you (indistinct)
on your media consumptions
on your phone and maybe
even a little on TV?
Are you a Netflix guy?
Have you started going
into those environments?
- Yeah, I am.
I mean, I enjoy watching
a lot of the products
produced today on television
in terms of Netflix
and Amazon products, et
cetera, are outstanding.
I have social media,
Instagram and Facebook.
I don't post anything,
but I really have 'em.
I told my kids some years
ago, I have six children.
So my youngest are two to 19,
but I told them about
six or seven years ago
when I went on social media.
I told them at dinner time,
that I was gonna do that
and just be able to follow them.
So you're smiling.
But at the time my
daughter, my twin brother
looked across the table,
said, Max, his name is Max.
Her name is Kylie.
She said, do you have
any idea what that means?
'Cause Max was like, he said, okay.
She said, that means dad's
gonna be following us,
following all of our posts.
We won't be able to say this,
that and the other thing.
So, I have it today
because I do follow my kids
and I follow some other
close friends in there--
- Do you follow any of the players,
any in soccer football team
(indistinct).
- No, I really don't.
But, I follow people like Jay Shetty,
I follow Deepak Chopra.
They're both very good friends.
There's some other people,
Simon Sinek, I follow.
I mean, there are a lot of
people that I do follow.
I'll follow you in the future.
I will definitely follow
you in the future.
I will.
- Thank you.
- Because you're covering
the kind of things
and have the kind of personality
that I would like to learn from.
So I think, (indistinct)
opportunities to learn from it.
I mean, to me, there's a
story I tell them the book
which, you may have picked
up you may not have.
When we had an opportunity to
participate in these sports.
And, it's a situation.
I mean, we're a private company,
we're not a public company, et cetera.
And they came in and our
management team had already decided
they really wanted to do this.
They wanted to participate in it.
They came up to the final presentation.
The marketing folks came
in and they presented it.
And one of the slides was
a picture of a young man
who had made, as I remember
some ungodly amount of money,
it was like 500,000 bucks.
He was like 12 or 14 years old,
but they said he practices 10 hours a day,
10, 12 hours a day to be
able to be competitive
at the level he's at.
So when they left the
room, the presenting team,
our management team was over there.
I said, we're not gonna do this.
And they said, well, why
are we not gonna do it?
I said, this has nothing
to do with our business,
it has to do with our values.
I said, I mean,
I don't wanna encourage
young people honestly
to sit in front of
technology, 10, 12 hours a day
when I think they should be outside
and they should be enjoying nature,
enjoy playing with each
other with a lot of
structured time or unstructured
time, whatever it may be.
But I don't think it's to
their best interests long term.
I do think, and you may or
may not agree with this.
But I think Gary, that
the level of connectivity
that we have today in the United States
or throughout the world
is at an all time high
and it's only gonna get more so.
But the level of neighborhood
that exists today
in the world is at an all time low.
And I think back to the way you
and I were raised in Queens,
the environment we were raised in,
where we were nurtured in a community.
Both in an apartment, I
had four family members
living in one tiny apartment.
You had eight, you lived in a community
where everybody supported each other.
Everybody came together, et cetera.
We need more of that in this country--
- To me, I think there's first of all
from a value filter standpoint
I couldn't agree with you more.
I think my take to your point
where it's skews a little bit different.
First of all, the admiration
I have for people,
I mean the amount of money
I have left on the table
because I need to feel good about it
is extraordinary and it is the single,
and I'm gonna say this very clearly
it is the single thing
that I'm most grateful for.
It's just a nice feeling.
There's no no payday
Interesting enough for me
to feel that feeling.
As a matter of fact, it's gonna lead
to a different question I
wanted to ask you desperately,
I just wanna get in my mind.
What I would say, Arthur, is
what I've been able to discover
because I've been so deep in the trenches.
And I think like anything,
there's a great Russian saying
(speaks in foreign language)
It basically means,
everything is at its best
when it's balanced.
So I think balance is something.
But who defines balance, parents, society,
there's all those variables.
I will say that people underestimate
the nature of community
that is built digitally
and the expanding of other views.
The counterpoint to that is,
especially in political times like this,
people start going only into places
where they hear affirmation
of their points of view.
So there's a whole lot here.
And this is, I think this
is a four hour dinner
conversation in itself.
(crosstalk)
Let me (indistinct) that
I'm very passionate about.
I'm enjoying something recently
that I think about when I
think about Good Company,
which is my inability to be canderous
in my youth as a manager and leader,
because I liked happy and
good and honey so much
that I would kind of swallow
micro-little transgressions.
Unfortunately though they
would ultimately lead
to enough little drops where I would
either at my worst, shock
and surprise someone
in their firing and then
make myself feel better
by saying how didn't
they realize they stunk,
and didn't take on accountability.
Over the last two to three years,
I would say I was on a two out of 10
when it came to candor as a leader
because I overvalued...
And it led to an, as you can imagine
this is gonna make sense to
you, it led to entitlement.
And a lot of things that
I had to work through.
I think I'm in 6.5 land right now
with an eye towards eight or nine.
And I'm excited about that.
In your journey to get you to a place
of these incredible accomplishments
and to be able to write
a book like Good Company.
What part of the formula
do you think you had to work on the most
and get the reps in
versus what came extremely natural to you
that rounded out your ability
to execute Good Company?
- Well, I would say it
relates to the first point
that you were making.
I'm a prostate cancer survivor
and I just got another PSA and was zero.
So I'm blessed, but I
would say, like cancer
when you see it, you need
to deal with it seriously,
you need to deal with it
early, if not, it's spreads.
So I think when you're
dealing with human behavior
within an organization,
when you see a bad behavior
you need to address it, you
need to take it on seriously.
It doesn't mean to fire
anybody, but it means that you,
you address it seriously.
- (indistinct)
- Yeah, and, because if
not, it is gonna spread.
And it's not gonna spread
just with that person,
but it will spread to other people.
So the expression of bad Apple,
(crosstalk)
- That part of the honey empire was easy.
The part was, I needed to learn a cadence
to your point where I would
cut the cancer every time.
It's why I've had what I've
had over these 25 years.
- Yeah.
- The process of getting to
the cutting was something
that I was short on.
I didn't do it in a way
that I feel great about in hindsight.
And I'm trying to build towards--
- Well, I think that, that usually comes
because it means somebody...
The whole notion of sink or swimming,
in business, I don't believe in.
There's nothing worse than
watching somebody die drowning.
So if you wanna put somebody
into sink or swim situation
make sure they're properly trained
make sure they can swim, make
sure they can see the shore
make sure you can throw them a life guard,
a life jacket rather, if you need to.
So, you really wanna train people,
put them in the best place
they can be for success
and try to make sure
they have all the tools
they need for that.
If you reach a point, I
would say with anybody
that despite all that,
they just don't get it,
don't fit in, don't get your
values, don't wanna live it.
So it's not, you're really
in many, in my experience
is that you're doing them a favor.
It's not fun for you to have
to beat them over the head
for the next 10 years and telling them,
constantly doing the wrong thing
and they don't get it, they don't get it.
Maybe they just don't
fit into your culture.
So you do it in a kind
way, in a caring way.
You let them go.
You let them move on to find
a different organization
that fits more with the
way they choose to operate.
So--
- When I asked you the
biggest growth of people that,
because this is, we're getting
into very fun territory
around emotional intelligence
and self awareness
and things that really matter.
- Right.
- If I just say to you,
think of the people that
you've seen grow the most
through your years from pre-Depot,
let alone Depot to today.
Does it automatically go in your mind?
Do you think of a Carol or a Suzy
or a Rick or a John?
- Yeah.
- Like, it's pretty, it's
pretty powerful to see that kind
of emotional growth now.
- Yeah, it is.
And I will tell you that
the hallmark to the success of Home Depot,
it was built on products, assortment,
service level product
knowledge, et cetera, et cetera.
But the truth of the matter
is to get to 2200 stores
where they are today.
It's really built on just one thing.
And that's understanding the
culture and living the culture.
I'll tell you one brief story that
when McKinsey was writing a
book on The War for Talent,
their partner in Chicago, their
senior partner in Chicago,
(indistinct) came to visit me last
after we interviewed 200 of our associates
in Canada, in United States and in Chile.
We're operating stores there as well.
And he said, I've talked
to 200 of your associates,
a lot of engineers, cashiers,
salespeople, store managers,
district managers, presidency divisions,
merchants, et cetera.
And every single one of
them talks about the culture
exactly the same way, they
don't use the same words
like it's memorized, and
you're just repeating it
but they understand the essence of it.
And they're living it.
He said, I don't know how you do that.
I've never met a company anywhere
in a lot of our McKinsey experience
that was able to able to do that.
And I think that's the essence
of what makes us successful
at Home Depot.
And what has made all of our
businesses successful today
is that the price to get
into the game of moving ahead
and being a leader, being a manager
is that you have to understand
and lead and be an ambassador
for the culture of all of our businesses
which we express there
in your own culture.
So in your case, Gary, it means that
sometimes the people
are the best technicians
the best this, the best that.
You can hire the best of those things,
but you can't always hire somebody
and train somebody to be the best
of the culture that you want to reflect
in your organization.
- Arthur, how competitive?
This is a fun question for me.
How competitive were you in seeing
how well the book was going to do?
- Well, to be honest with you,
all the proceeds are being donated
to the National Civil
Rights Museum in Atlanta
which I'm proud of,
it's a great place and--
- Good news Arthur.
I definitely didn't think
this was a financial exercise
for you,
- No, it's not.
- But winners win and I
know that you didn't need,
I'm sure there were
some buddies you've had
that have written business books
that you wanted to sell one more than.
- You know what?
I only care about one thing, honestly.
That the book gets out in the hands
of as many people as it can.
And primarily if I had to
choose, if you pressed me
and you might, you press
me, well which population?
I would say the younger population.
The people, your listeners,
the people that are
gonna be thinking about
how do I live life with a purpose?
How do I run a business with a purpose?
How do I connect to not just myself
and my family and my own circle of love,
but to the greater need
of serving humanity
in a broad sense?
And, I feel strongly
that young people today
are pressing on those
questions more and more.
And I think we're blessed
by having a younger
population that's doing that.
So I would encourage,
that's who you listeners are
and I would encourage them to
continue to press that way.
And, they pick up the book or
trade it amongst themselves,
amongst 10 people.
So only is sold but 10 read
it, that's all I care about.
Do they read it?
Do they understand it?
Do they understand they can
have that balance in life
where they feel like, life
is being fulfilling to them.
And they're getting confused
between their work and their play.
The whole Zen philosophies
that you don't go to work
you gotta play every day.
And, that's kind of what
we try to relate to.
- I'm gonna have
(indistinct) who set this up,
connect me with some of your book people.
I think there's some
really fun gamification
you can do in social that allows people
to act on good behavior to win a copy
of the book that I think would
probably make you very happy.
'Cause you'd went on two fronts,
there'd be good put into the world
and another human would
consume it, and so--
- That would be great
- I got the thought
when you were just talking
that I wanna (indistinct)
- Please, thank you.
That'd be a blessing for me.
- Arthur, I really,
really don't wanna go here
because even though you
mentioned him as a friend.
If you can imagine as a New York Jets fan
that has watched every
single snap since 1982,
I have an uncomfortably
difficult situation
with the New England Patriots.
This is something we also share
what can we learn from a
moment like that Superbowl
that must have hurt quite a bit.
- It did, first of all, it's
certainly a good question.
When you're leading 28 to three
in the middle of third quarter,
you almost think there's
almost no way to lose the game.
I mean, I really wasn't thinking
(crosstalk)
- Yeah, that's right.
To me, I'm such a cynical Jets fan,
that if you are 49-3
with two minutes left.
I am still not talking to anybody.
- I am as well, all right?
Even though it's was
20-3, I wasn't thinking--
- There was a piece of
your brain thinking about
some excitement, but you
were pretty locked into--
- I was very locked in.
And as the game started to
trend in the wrong direction
as we got to the third and fourth quarter,
it was interesting, my mind went to,
I'm a father of six, a grandfather of six,
is that, how do I be a
source of comfort, wisdom,
counsel, support for my family,
our players, our coaches, our fans.
So it went away from myself
to how do I help others get
through this horrific time?
And that's what my focus was.
I think I probably wasn't
until maybe a year later or so
that I went through the
personal, paying myself
because I know as you know,
you're a football fan.
32 teams, it's very hard to
get back to the super bowl.
It takes a single game
elimination in the playoffs,
so, the ball is not round,
a lot of things can happen.
And--
- (indistinct), like when I'm
in my most down in business
and things of that nature
because of my upbringing
and the humble nature,
and just the deep pain of
generational suppression
in the Soviet union, I really
do care about something
as silly as football.
I mean, at least it's your team.
This is like my, my fandom.
And I get into a very serious place.
I do find...
By the way during COVID
I had a lot of friends...
We are still in it.
But like in the early kind
of like first 12, 16 weeks,
I had a lot of friends going through
some pretty difficult times.
And I really tried to deploy
perspective to them of like
just be grateful for what you
have, not what you've lost.
I remember seeing a one friend
who was really struggling
Hey, you do understand
that if COVID started eight weeks earlier,
Kobe Bryant would probably be
alive for the next 50 years.
Let's put this into perspective.
I understand you're worried about money.
I understand you are
worried about a wedding,
which is very important,
but still let's really
put this in perspective.
Do you tend to go into that place.
- I tend not to go to
the dark place, Gary.
What I tend to do is go to the place
to be very much like you described.
I mean, I'm blessed,
I have a great family.
We have great businesses.
Our golf business is an example
which is just the counter, has taken off,
I've never seen Comp sales in retail
in my 50 years of retail
that we are experiencing.
- (indistinct)
It's just incredible.
But to our own associates,
with football, soccer, ranches,
which we closed.
The first time in 100
years they've been closed.
This is 2020.
We'll get through this.
It's a period of time.
2021, we'll be fine.
We'll go through a transition early 2021,
and then we'll be fine going on.
And keeping perspective of all the things
we have blessings over.
Everybody has blessings over.
So I also know that like our foundation
we've probably granted 40, $50 million
just dealing with emergency
situations due to COVID
in terms of food, safety, and health
and things of that nature.
We've helped, how many
non-profits just get
through this period of time.
Because these are great organizations
that will do great work
in 2021 and beyond that.
And so we need to help them
get through this period of time.
So, we had a meeting here last night,
talking about a variety of
things with our leadership team.
And I said, this is a year
you take care of your friends.
You take care of your family.
You take care of your
people that you care about,
which for us is all of our
guests, all of our fans,
all of our customers and
take care of your associates.
And then you worry about
other things in 2021.
It's just, that's the
attitude we have to have.
- It's a tremendous way
to end this interview.
Arthur, thank you for your time.
- Thank you for your time, Gary.
I appreciate it, God bless.
(energetic music)
- Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so
much, so humbled for your time.
I don't wanna watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.